you take a lot of chances
councilman you're worried about your
ship captain
i'm trying to save a world
if i were you
i think about saving my life
that's from star trek the original
series it premiered on television more
than 50 years ago the science fiction
show went on to become one of the most
iconic franchises in history earning
billions of dollars there have been six
different shows on television including
an animated series and 13 feature films
and guess what there's another the
newest tv reboot star trek discovery
launches this month on cbs all access it
features new characters new missions and
a new ship and a new actress senniqua
martin green takes to the screen she
played sasha on amc's the walking dead
if she looks familiar to you now she
stars as first officer michael
burnham in this preview she's on a
mission with the starships captain
what will you do if you were stuck here
for 89 years
a likely scenario unless we die here in
the desert let's say you lived
as a zeno anthropologist i could reveal
myself to the natives learn their
culture try to fit in
if possible
and you captain
what will you do if we're trapped here
for 89 years that's easy i'd escape
these are our footprints
you've walked us in a circle
not exactly a circle
siniqua martin greene is the first black
woman to play the lead in a star trek
series that's a big deal she joins us at
the table welcome thank you thank you
first black woman to play the lead yes
we'll talk about that in just a second
but first it was so frustrating because
they would not release any of the video
they would not let us have an episode
the only thing we could see is a trailer
why all the secrecy you don't have to
worry about it leaking out nobody got to
see it
i know i think i think there's a lot of
things at play there i think i think
it's because of of how big it is because
of everything that's been put into it i
think i think they're just very
protective of it and they want to
protect everyone's experience and
journey of it let me just say based on
that it looks huge it doesn't look like
a tv show it looks like a movie thank
you it's beautiful
beautifully shot what can you tell us
about that i i tell you what i think the
craftsmanship on this show is through
the roof i am floored by everyone's
artistry i really am every single
department in front of the camera behind
the camera the the crew the crew the
cast the producing team the writers i
just i i feel that everyone is at their
highest potential honestly i love the
idea that star trek discovery is
actually a prequel happens a decade
before the original star trek series and
you are spock's adopted sister
wow nora
how is that and can can can we cut to
seneca here and please can you do the
sign oh i mean are you legit
higher higher all right legit
[Laughter]
it's i i appreciate um how courageous
this story is
and i appreciate how they have woven me
into that family because spock is an
institution yeah so do you have pointy
ears i do not because you adopt it
i mean yeah i'm 100 human my parents
were killed when i was when i was very
young and it happened at a vulcan
outpost and so they took responsibility
for me and i i was commissioned to uh
cerric and amanda's care so i became
their surrogate daughter and then
thereby so do you have vulcan qualities
or definitely there has been a serious
vulcan indoctrination okay for sure
there i i had to i'm i was forced to
assembly okay
did you say on a recent panel that
somehow looking at star trek discovery
can give you some
entree to solutions for today's problems
i i think so and and that seems like a
lofty thing to say right but i think
that it's very i think that it can be
very profound because
obviously stories can be so healing um
art is so healing and i think that when
you have a story that shows a picture of
a utopian future
i think especially it's been this way
the entire time this is the legacy of
star trek and i think that when you can
when you can tap into that when you can
key into that i think that having a
vision of it can help you actualize it
you know when it was first announced
that you were going to be the first
woman of color you had some haters not
everybody was happy with the decision
that couldn't have been pleasant for you
was it painful
it was to be honest it was a bit hurtful
but i
i'm a black woman that was uh raised in
the south
so
uh it did not surprise me um because i
am used to
i'm used to that unfortunately
uh but it's a it's a double-sided
coin right because on one end i wasn't
surprised on the other end i sort of was
because
diversity and universality
are you know they're
they're pillars of star trek that is the
legacy of it speaking of that legacy i
didn't realize this until going back
over the research for this that in 1968
nichelle nichols and william shatner
made television history with their
interracial the first interracial kiss
on television yeah was was in the
original series did the tvs explode
i know you would think so right
now
i know that no one star trek has always
gone boldly yeah it always has that's
been the essence of it um and i think no
man has gone before that
does discovery continue that absolutely
how does it do absolutely well we do
that because you know we're upholding
the legacy but but again taking that
next step forward because here i am the
first black female lead we've got the
first asian female captain we've got the
first woman captain uh with a woman
first officer and you have a very creepy
guy with blue eyes
what a champion he's a kelpie oh my god
and so he's the first of his kind we're
introducing his species
he's a kelpie a kelpie yeah very creepy
yeah
and people like creepy i know yeah the
design is gorgeous for sure and we've
got the first openly gay officer and you
know on a surface
in starfleet on a star trek show so it's
we're we're we're doing it we're
continuing it that's and that's how you
do it so the so the naysayers i think
it's completely antithetical if you say
you're a long time trek fan it doesn't
well the truckies are going to love it
my family included we are truckies in my
family watched it thank you yes we're
cheering you on cynical martin greene
thank you so much
a special broadcast premiere of star
trek discovery will air september 24th
at 8 30 7 30 central on cbs and after
the premiere all new episodes will be
available on cbs all access trekkies